venga para Furtado literally would like
the maritime borders in the
Mediterranean to be reinforced because
these are the external borders of Europe
agencia kamata front exit Davis curare
main yo Nell make we have an agency
called Frontex which must operate in
Mediterranean near Italy we're expecting
European help for Italy to resettle
these immigrants que pase sera de una
mano de Yuto alitalia nella dislocate
Sione's de mi grant e dopo in law rosal
botado cheese urban anche UT economics
in questo sin so cozy commercially amo
que venga coordinate a una task force
we'd also like a task force coordinated
by the European Union to be set up in
the mediterranean sea front are in cma
cuesta de galicia was the owner was he
using i'm going to propose to member
states that we organize a big Frontex
operation covering all of the
mediterranean from cyprus to Spain for a
save and rescue operation in the
Mediterranean I'm going to ask for the
support and the resources necessary to
be able to do that to save more lives
worked a lot of him boys and Indians is
among those four I want to point out
that front X has saved 40,000 people
from the sea in the last two years after
that also c naught andaz frantic skies
not just an instrument for segregation
some people claim but supports member
states in the awareness of their tasks
you know of gum the thread is via missin
midland start now secondly we need to
discuss how to tackle the causes of
people fleeing African countries became
from on Fulton server than be locked
office or thirdly we must fight people
traffickers fourthly we should see with
the Italian authorities at the local
level that the conditions for refugees
in a lab Medusa are appropriate mention
about the human dissenter under the
n-dimensional mcentire Bratton Yertle a
blog entry serios peau de loup Adichie
Italians we've talked about the measures
which we in the EU have at our disposal
to prevent this kind of tragedy from
happening again at the future Ramona's
Korea's que para pasar younga to rimac
at panache Australia's nessa car Toto
Ness viski potato Joe severity we have
to use not only the means that we have
available in the EU we also have to
enhance our cooperation with the
countries at the southern Mediterranean
the countries of origin and transit of
migrants pre- or oppa saranghae
baterista print a vendre dared ademas
sous-vide origina euros patoka minimis
oscuro arbiter quiesce VK for the global
approach to migration and mobility is
one of the many nations uma hora vienes
is sort of a su primo no i will now with
from tex and my services working with
member states authorities to address the
needs and to set up the organization of
this we need the tragedy shows to act at
the European level to a much bigger
extent than we have so far